[Music]
so last year
i think it was november uh i was
i was kind of at a point in my life
where i was making
serious decisions i had separated i was
separated from my husband
uh for about a year and a half and
i kind of like sorted out my head in
that year and a half and i got to a
place where i felt stable enough to be
able to do a high dose of a psychedelic
at that point it's psilocybin so uh
i i felt stable enough i was like you
know what i'm gonna be able to go into
this and learn
something so i had
seven grams in tea and
that's a good amount oh my god for the
listeners yeah uh
maybe it may be starting i'm actually a
fan
of larger doses i'm not i i don't like
to be prescriptive to anybody else but
for myself personally
i i think yeah the five grams was what
terence mckenna
would call the heroic yes which i
thought was the most poorly named
i i wish he wouldn't have
made it sound like such a heroic journey
or whatever but i actually think that's
a good place to start
so anyways really i i do
oh wow i'd had like i've i've done them
a bunch before that i'd never done that
many
i'd done two i i didn't really like
anything under two
i found two to three and a half got me
to this point where i had a lot of
control over it and it was kind of this
uncomfortable
period where i was like oh maybe i don't
want to venture into that and i could
try really hard and stop myself but i
find for me
anything over four uh and i don't have
an option
yeah i i don't like giving myself the
option i i find that uh
anxiety those middle grounds are
unsettling and
more confusing and they can be helpful
as well but they've they've
they've actually the the half the half
dose
so in in many psilocybin and mdma trials
they've done full dose placebo and then
for a while they were doing half doses
and they
they've cut half doses from really
studies that i know for that very reason
they've actually they've actually seen
people
have a uh if anything sometimes negative
impact from
from the half doses or or interesting
not as much help so so usually there's
there's
some help within the placebo group
because you're still getting lots of
therapy and everything
and then there's a huge impact in the
in the full dose and the half dose
it seems it seems to be that for a lot
of people it's just kind of confusing
and unsettling
whereas the full doses it kind of takes
a little bit of the control
from you and you you tend to surrender
to it a little bit more and there's a
certain
clarity um to it so
uh so yeah so go on yeah so um
i i had no control right it
started and it was it was interesting it
started and i saw these trolls and
i was laying on a mattress and they were
there were these trolls in the
in the corner watching me i've never
gotten trolls i've never
gotten the trolls yourself you've never
gotten i've gotten trolls
they're not the purple lady they're like
little gremlin-like things
um and i've had them actually both
experiences that i saw the purple lady i
also saw trolls
but it was weird i could see trolls in
the corner so i could
this is when i could still see so i
could see the ceiling i could see these
trolls watching me
i got up to use the bathroom came back
the trolls were still there so they were
stuck in one area watching me and then
when i fell into it
uh when i fell into it
i probably cried for most of the
experience you know and it was from what
i've read about
really high-dose mushroom experiences it
was totally typical
like i i went through every relationship
in my life and saw how i was
contributing negatively to it
uh i ended it with an overwhelming sense
of
if you're going to put anything into the
universe it should be love
because anything you put that's negative
just adds to
the negativity in the universe i went
what i would say was outer space but it
kind of
looked like uh the beatles yellow
submarine
it was so the beatles yellow submarine
where it was kind of a cart
kind of cartoon-like i couldn't see
anything right like i was way out in
outer space
uh and there were all these different
beings there
and it's hard to remember
i'd have to go back and see what i wrote
maybe i'll put that put it in the show
notes because it was more in depth
but there were there were all these
different beings and it filled me with a
sense i lost myself completely
right so i wouldn't say i had i don't
know if that qualified as an ego death
but i didn't exist anymore
and i went to this place where nothing
mattered like
nothing mattered and i thought and it
was a relief that nothing mattered
anymore
and then i kind of built it back up and
thought because i have a daughter
and i thought wait a minute some things
matter to me
they might not matter in the greater
scheme of things but my daughter
certainly matters to me and that's okay
and maybe it's better that some things
matter even if
they don't according to this this place
i was in
uh and then at that point my dad was
really ill uh and he was having a
he he's he had a physical dependency on
benzodiazepines
that just that almost killed him right
like those those drugs are just
people don't know how dangerous they are
but uh he had a paradoxical reaction and
it was killing him at that time
and it was very confusing for our family
because we were like what's going on
we didn't know what was going on for a
while and so i saw him
in this trip and he was encompassed in
this black [ __ ] demon
and i looked at the demon and i thought
oh my god
that tar demon used to have me and i
used to be really ill i had
i was on a lot of medication i was
extremely depressed i had arthritis
and i got healthy i got off of all those
meds but i looked at the tar demon and i
had this overwhelming sense of
i know you and so it's not my dad who's
like who's the bad guy kind of in the
situation he's he's being had by this
tar demon
so i went in to grab the tar demon to
pull him away
and he grabbed my arm and started
sucking me in and i was like okay
i can't pull him out and then
this purple so i i was filled with rage
at this tar demon
and then this purple lady came and this
is over the expanse of what felt like a
thousand
years because it was like four hours of
not being able to see
uh and this purple lady came and for me
she was
it was kind of 2d and very digital
and she floated over me and it looked a
lot like that hockenism
photo it was kind of flat she was just
ahead
and she floated over me and i was filled
with a sense
of it's okay you're doing everything
right everything's going to be okay
it was overwhelming sense of that and
she just
she didn't say anything right she was
just looking at me and i could just feel
that through her eyes
and she just hung out there and then
this trip
slowly ended and that was the first time
i saw her but i ended up seeing her
again
on aco dmt um but that was the first
time i saw her and i was like i have
seen
god after that it was like like nothing
nothing matters fill the universe with
love
don't contribute negativity um
it completely got rid of my fear of
death because it kind of felt like an
after life experience
and then i saw this purple
god lady and it had a really lasting
impression in me